[Music]
some people call me a hero others call
me a freak jessica jones season two
starts streaming March 8th on Netflix I
feel like I'm I'm as eager to see it's
season 2 as the fans are and it's all
about strong women anything bad Miss
Jones
yeah I always see what threats head-on
meaning I punch them in the head until
they're unconscious on ad off-screen
she's just a total a total badass
I love everything about her she's funny
she's dark she's the real deal
she's utterly compelling what's the
actress and the characters so how is
anger management still angry and get
this all 13 episodes of the second
season were directed by women a
conscious and intentional choice I've
got to make a decision one keep denying
it her to do something about it
plus the Jerry Hogarth character was
changed from a man in the comics to a
woman for the series casting is gender
blind what Melissa has done across the
board with all of the characters is
she's really written these incredibly
complex strong independent women that
really have a place to grow over the
course of the series the show is
following Hollywood's lead it's time
that women stand together across all
industries 2018 is totally the year of
the woman and that with discrimination
and harassment and abuse
we deserve equality and that time is up
tinsel town's biggest stars are stepping
up and speaking out for equality and
change we're not bringing the voice to
the voiceless we're just amplifying
those who have been saying this year
after year after year decade after
decade we're feeling charged there's a
new energy in the air I think it's
something to embrace standing in
solidarity and I think that's really
really powerful it's something for me
that's very important to have more
female voices and positions in positions
of power and it's just I think it's a
really important moment to to change
those numbers in terms of women who are
writer director producers executives all
of it there's something something
brewing inside all the more reason to
get to work and try and make the changes
that we know we need to make in our
culture in our society we have a
deadline yeah a deadline for this
deadline it's coming soon so we've got
to get going
[Music]